[Musique]
invité de sarkozy ce matin bruno nestor
azérot le nouveau maire de sète marie
bonjour bruno nestor azérot pour alain
livre hui merci pour cette invitation
alors est-ce que vous avez retrouvé
récupérer la voiture et des clés de
votre bureau
mais déjà remercier toutes celles et
tous ceux qui ont porté leurs suffrages
sur une hausse c'est à dire la laisse
que j'ai la chance de conduire et moi
même et puis a remercié la population
parce qu'effectivement j'ai retrouvé les
clés de l'hôtel de ville
vous avez lancé une mise en garde assez
explicite aux employés municipaux de la
ville
il règne chasse aux sorcières à
l'intérieur non il n'ya pas de chasse
aux sorcières il y aura une mise à plat
de l'organisation municipale c'est à
dire que rappeler aux administratifs que
seuls les élus décident dès qu'ils sont
là pour exécuter la commune politique
je crois que ce qui s'est passé pendant
ces élections 20les mes yeux on veut un
certain nombre de choses mais nous
voyons en lui un certain nombre de
choses et je considère tout simplement
que chacun doit respecter ce pour quoi
il est payé et ça que doit rester dans
ses missions c'est à dire les élus font
de la politique les administratifs font
leur travail et administratifs est-ce
que l'on peut être employé municipal
dont fonctionnaire territorial avoir des
idées et avoir des idées différentes de
celles du maire en place mais être aimé
être comment dire très efficace dans son
travail bien ce qu'il faut absolument
être corps et âme
à brunehaut nestrasil assumer mais pas
du tout je ne les ai jamais fait
rappeler tout simplement que nous sommes
quand même dans une démocratie donc la
démocratie veut dire plein de choses et
a dit qu'il ya une liberté de penser de
faire et d'agir maintenant un agent
municipal qui quelque part en dehors de
ses heures de travail fait de la
politique ça ne me gêne pas du tout mais
quand il le fait pendant ses heures de
travail c'est ce n'est pas la même chose
c'est différent et puis rappelé
également que de tout temps ça a
toujours existé
je crois que cette marie effectivement
c'est une ville qu'on peut considérer
comme très chaude comme étant une ville
politique mais ce qu'il faut surtout
dire c'est que si chacun ne reste pas à
sa place si la porte ouverte à n'importe
quoi donc je pense qu'il est un rappel à
l'ordre de la faire au niveau de la
collectivité samaritaine qui depuis un
certain temps en tout cas depuis à peu
près quatre mois fait n'importe quoi
donc je considère que celle de ceux qui
ont porté leurs suffrages sur nos nous
ont donné mandat pour atout car remettre
la ville de sète maillot travail
remettre les agents au travail et
demandent aux politiques de faire de la
politique pour que cette marie continue
son développement pour que les sam a été
de samaritaine puisse vivre de tout cet
épanouissement
lors de l'installation du conseil
municipal samedi dernier ils manquèrent
visage celui de jean philippe lors le
député du sud
on sait qu'il a dans un communiqué
condamné vos propos sur le charnier ce
sont des mots que vous regrettez
aujourd'hui je crois que j'ai eu
l'occasion de me prononcer là-dessus
mais je le ferai avec grand plaisir ce
matin vous savez c'est l'action qui fait
la réaction rappeler que nous étions
charlier c'est quand même votre effort
non je suis tout à fait d'accord avec
vous je crois que ce qu'il est important
c'est que il y a eu pendant cette
campagne
le deux camps c'est à dire un camp qui
proposait à dire qu'ils qui faisait
passer des idées et des projets pour le
devenir des samaritaine des samaritains
et puis un autre cas qui s'est attaqué à
la personne bout d'1h30 doxa est une
campagne quand même très difficile
rappelé également que je n'ai jusqu'à
aujourd'hui pas compris pourquoi pour
une petite élection partielle à cette
marie il y avait quand même temps des
deux mondes de la ctm et notamment son
président qui sont venus à cette maille
pour prêter main forte raison pas de
vocation et même des mots que vous
regrettiez jour je m'en excuse si j'ai
pu blesser si j'ai pu froisser les uns
les autres à travers ce mot bonjour lady
sur un autre média
donc je m'en excuse ici publiquement sur
les antennes de martinique 1ère
cependant je rappelle que c'est l'action
qui fait la réaction dans un dans votre
discours d'installation vous avez aussi
présenté deux orientations d'abord
municipal la poursuite du programme 2014
2020 mais aussi une visée politique
en ligne de mire la ctn et cap nord vous
voulez conquérir la 7e je crois à
d'autres peut-être mais vous les coui
bien sûr c'est à dire que nous sommes
dans une démarche depuis bien longtemps
il faut rappeler le parler du g20 par
exemple qui sera réactivé depuis un
certain temps effectivement nous étions
en nombre assez important de maire et
d'autres élus et des personnalités
civiles qui avons décidé un moment donné
de de discuter d'échanger pour proposer
un projet où martiniquais en vue de la
prochaine c'est m donc c'est vrai que
nous sommes toujours de cette démarche
là qui sera réactivée puisqu'il fallait
avec cris le jv sera-t-il réactiver on
parle de vous de nadau denis l'or mais
aussi de thirau oui je pense que là
c'est une affaire martiniquaise donc
nous ne sommes pas dans des clivages
politiques ne sont pas dans des camps
politiques
nous sommes tout simplement des hommes
et des femmes de droite de gauche ou
d'ailleurs et alliances contre nature là
n'ont entendu non pas du tout par non
non non moi je vous savez j'ai toujours
respecté les délais les partis
politiques je considère que le parti
politique n'est ce pas une science
exacte
hausser de la doua du lr vous avez des
gens formidables vous avez des gens qui
ont envie de porter une certaine
responsabilité martinken et je leur fais
confiance pour cela tout comme vous en
avez
à gauche vous même donc je crois que ce
qui va se passer là c'est effectivement
ce qu'a fait à peu près emmanuel macron
que nous avions initiée avant lui
d'ailleurs c'est peut-être de mettre en
commun des énergies des synergie des
intelligences et puis surtout des envies
de sortir lamenté dans cet état dans
lequel il est aujourd'hui puisque tous
les indicateurs comme tout le monde le
dit vous également les médias que les
indicateurs sont au rouge donc il faut
absolument sauver ce pays
c'est quoi votre dénominateur commun
quand on voit le panel de personnes
autour de vous quel est le dénominateur
commun des intelligences collectives
c'est-à-dire des envies collective et
puis surtout un projet collectif pour
sortir la marche avec 2 7 de cette
situation dont je crois que est-ce que
vous nous ne serions à lui tout seul
plus porter cette responsabilité
martiniquaise hossein la 7e pas du tout
est ce que michel michel thibault peut
le faire tout seul non pas du tout est
ce que jean philippe belloc le faire
tout seul ou encore marie nadeau pas du
tout deux jours parce qu effectivement
nous sommes des élus et responsables qui
depuis un certain temps puisque nous
avons été investi par nos populations
porteo est louable dépens de population
donc celle ci attend beaucoup de nous et
notamment ce qu'attendent les
populations des hommes politiques c'est
de se mettre ensemble pour que nous
fassions quelque chose pour la matinée
on regarde un peu ce qui se passe en
cause donc il ya quand même une majorité
qui a souhaité faire quelque chose pour
la côte d'or c'est ce que nous c'est ce
que nous demande en tout cas les martin
régime a entraîné quelques ornements
allez vous faire pour que par exemple
jean philippe miller mais le combat avec
vous il faudra qu'ils s'affranchissent
du monde moi je ne veux pas faire de
l'ingérence vous savez j'en fais les
mener là on fait partie du même
effectivement bien assez grand pour
prendre des décisions si c'est
exactement ça les plus de 50 ans va me
répondait césium a ici pas ça brise à
ces problèmes les mémoires à penser
qu'avec et points personnellement j'ai
pris mes décisions et bientôt sauter
qu'il s'écarte un peu du mime c'est ça
je ne souhaite rien du tout comment vous
allez faire s'il ne s'écarte pas du mime
non mais je n'ai pas mais je le dis je
n'ai pas de la faire de l'ingérence dans
les affaires du même maintenant j'avais
le nez lors je pense que depuis un
certain temps et là un certain nombre de
difficultés au sein de son parti
politique c'est pas moi qui le dit c'est
lui-même et c'est les eaux maintenant
c'est à lui de voir que c'est ce qui me
plaît dans capacité de s'affranchir ou
pas maintenant dans ce dispositif de ce
projet dans cette envie dans cette idée
qui est la nôtre et ben je pense que
jean philippe nuel aura toute sa place
et rien de sa place de riz va falloir
bien évidemment compter avec lui sur vue
maintenant mes mots quand même ça c'est
son problème qu'est ce qu'ils peuvent en
2015 n'avez pas réussi à vous entendre
qu est ce qui fait qu'aujourd'hui tout
cela c'est très possible c'est la
situation dramatique du pays qui nous
l'imposent quand vous entendez les
acteurs économiques quand vous entendez
nos artisans qu'on nous entende et
toutes celles et tous ceux qui peuvent
faire la richesse de notre pays
eh ben je crois que vous êtes dans
l'obligation de proposer quelque chose
donc je pense que ce qui n'a pas marché
hier peut marcher aujourd'hui et
peut-être de ne plus marcher demain donc
je pense que nous sommes dans une vie ou
malheureusement c'est comme ça que les
choses de ce fonds ne peut pas après
l'autre
donc ce n'est pas parce que ça n'a pas
marché hier qu'il ne faut pas tenter
aujourd'hui c'est ce que nous allons
faire ou a tenté aujourd'hui
autre priorité cap nord en fait vous
êtes en train de dire au maire du robert
frais de mon dieu qu'il faut qu'en 2020
qu'ils pensent à prendre sa retraite
je n'ai jamais dit ça quand je n'ai
jamais dit ça il faut être une monture
est un ami et frère de mon dieu en tout
cas a été celui que nous avons porté aux
responsabilités de 4 no 3 qu'il fait un
travail considérable
maintenant je pense que l'automne
prochain cède sa place lors du prochain
conseil communautaire je pense que le 22
le bureau d'un cap nord et à partir de
cela nous allons travailler ensemble
comme un seul homme comme nous le font
pour porter le territoire nord qui en
2011 de la place le ternois qui voyagent
beaucoup d'atouts donc là maintenant on
fera avec et frais de mon pied avec un
feu de buvards avec marie thérèse quasi
muet avec tous les autres nous sommes
quand même des élus du nord qui voulons
faire décoller le nord d'occitan somme
que nous pourrons le faire maintenant
concernant ma nul à clermont désire
comment vous allez procéder
comment ça va se passer vous allait
démissionner je crois que vous avez une
rencontre avec le président de
l'assemblée nationale 2
juillet c'est à dire que nous nous
partons manuela mots désuets moi même
le onze projets c'est-à-dire lundi et
nous avons une semaine pour nous pour
régler tout ce qui mérite d'être réglée
tant politiquement qu'administrativement
à l'assemblée nationale doit partir de
cela que je verrai comment faire
exactement mais il est évident que
manuel mondésir désormais va porter en
tout cas la responsabilité législatives
dans la circonscription et d'ailleurs je
demande aux populations de ces deux
façades de la conception façade
atlantique et caribou de l'église avait
un bon accueil de lui faire confiance je
suis persuadé qu'elle mènera la cie
consulter le plus haut poste
vous avez transmis une feuille de route
ma nuit là à mon désir c'est clair
morisien je n'ai pas transmis de foot
c'est à dire que nous sommes mis
d'accord sur un certain nombre de choses
notamment qu'elle intègre le groupe gdr
le groupe des démocrates et républicains
doc c'est déjà le cas et pourquoi
l'intégration de ce groupe
tout simplement parce que nous avions
dès le départ d'affilée p moi même et
les autres gabriel servi les autres et
bien intégré ce groupe parce que nous
avions une liberté de vote
donc c'est ce qui va toujours
conditionné l'entrée de manuela mot
désert au sein de ce groupe
et puis bien sûr nous avons un président
andré chassaigne qui est un homme
d'expérience qui connaît très bien le
les ouailles parlementaire donc je suis
persuadé que manu la mode et ce sera
bien accueilli et produire de très bons
résultats venant de très bons résultats
bruno nestor azérot merci d'avoir
répondu à notre invitation bonne journée
aller coûte de nos programmes avoua même
merci beaucoup à un niveau 8
[Musique]
et après la politique en ont parlé
d'agriculture tout à l'heure grégory
ghabbour qui nous emmèneront à oman a
justement voici france info à 12h30
simon le baron il se décrivait lui-même
comme un homme de droite avec beaucoup
d'idées de gauche gens dorment sont fait
l'unanimité ce matin dans la classe
politique de jean luc mélenchon à
laurent wauquiez en passant par françois
hollande alain juppé ou évidemment la
ministre de la culture françoise nyssen
tous et toutes rendent hommage à
l'écrivain et académicien